puedes poner eso después de ocho años la
familia de noureddine por fin regresa a
su casa en mosúl donde la ciudad vieja
que fue casi completamente destruida
durante la guerra
no tengo palabras para describir mi
felicidad hoy es una sensación increíble
estar de vuelta en tu propio hogar en tu
ciudad en tu casa recordar aunque gran
parte del centro histórico sigue en
ruinas la casa de su familia fue
reconstruida por completo por la unesco
que se ha comprometido a hacer lo mismo
con otro centenar
sin ayuda externa habría sido realmente
difícil reconstruir mosúl porque la
mayoría de los que viven en la ciudad
vieja son pobres
el gobierno debía indemnizar nos pero
está tardando en repartir los fondos
pero estas familias que reciben ayuda
son las más afortunadas la gran mayoría
de los residentes solo pueden contar con
ellos mismos estos dos residentes de
mosúl lograron reconstruir su casa
dañada
rehicimos toda la entrada luego el
interior todo estaba agrietado las
ventanas estaban destruidas hubo que
reparar todo incluso las escaleras costó
cuatro mil euros en total una suma
considerable que estos iraquíes tuvieron
que ahorrar durante años desde que la
ciudad fue liberada muchos se han
sentido decepcionados por la lentitud
del gobierno en regenerar la vida de la
ciudad destrozada por la guerra para
llenar el vacío ha surgido una vibrante
sociedad civil en este café los
voluntarios celebran haber organizado un
gran festival de música en mosúl
somos como los cirujanos de esta ciudad
de nuestra ciudad mosúl necesita muchas
iniciativas ciudadanas porque es la más
antigua que fue destruida durante la
guerra
la idea de este local era atraer
cualquier tipo de evento al centro de la
ciudad vieja y sinceramente no
pensábamos que fuera a funcionar tan
bien como lo hice bajar cinco años
después y a pesar de que mosúl todavía
se tambalea por la devastación de la
guerra los residentes están
reconstruyendo su vida poco a poco